[موسيقى]
قد تكون قد رايت اعلانات القوارب الخارقه
المتطوره كليا مثل القارب الشبح الذي يضم
مرتفعا عن سطح الماء على غطاء من الفقاعات
او البرود الذي يسير عكس الامواج التي يصل
ارتفاعها الى سته عشر قدما وعندما يكون
الطاقم ال مستعده لاطلاق النار فان
الرشاشه وقاذفات القنابل تظهر من ظهر
السفينه وقال مصمم القارب فرانك والتي ان
الشرطه من حول العالم مهتمه بشراء ما يقوم
ببيعه لكن كيف يمكن للقوارب مثل هذه ان
تتوافق مع استراتيجيات الدفاع في القرن
الحادي والعشرين الخبراء يقولون انها قد
تجد الدول الاصغر للدفاع عن سواحلها ضد
الارهابيين والمجموعات الثوريه او مهربي
المخدرات
اما القوات البحريه ال كبيره مثل الولايات
المتحده فقد لا يكون لديها نفس الاهتمام
الباحث الاستراتيجي في ترسيم غير يقول ان
قوات البحريه الكبرى تركز اكثر على الجيل
الجديد من السفن الحربيه الضخمه والغواصات
لتاكيد نفوذها في المياه الدوليه ولتامين
السواحل فان الخبراء يقولون ان القوارب
غير ماهوله السطح او ما تعرف بيو اسميه قد
توفر امكانيات اكثر فهي اصغر حجما واقل
كلفه وعمليه اكثر ورغم ذلك فان القوات
الخاصه والمسعفين قد يرغبون بالحصول على
قوارب تسمح لهم بنقل البشر فبعض المهام قد
تتطلب اتخاذ قرارات في الموقع وهذا امر لا
يمكن القيام به باستخدام القوارب غير
الماهوله في الوقت الراهن على الاقل